is there a moment of your career that
you wish you could do over
you know
um
yes me no
that's probably because he can't
remember anything at this point I don't
know we just got our hands on the 359
page transcript of fauci's seven hour
long Depot with the attorneys General of
Missouri and Louisiana
now during that deposition he said I
don't recall
174 times when he was asked about his
own emails now that doesn't even include
all the times he said I can't recall and
I don't remember that's even a lot more
now remember he the one thing he does
remember is sending Dr Clifford Lane one
of his deputies on a who delegation to
China in February of 2020 to see how
they were handling covid and boy they
amazed Dr Lane was very impressed about
how the Chinese were handling the
isolation the contact tracing and the
building of facilities to take care of
the people he also said that lane
reported back from the trip that China
learned lessons about controlling the
virus that they wanted to share with us
fauci was on the angle at the exact same
time the who delegation was over there
getting information from their Chinese
Pals So you're satisfied with all of the
transparency coming out of China today
about the trajectory of the disease and
the origin of the disease
Laura I cannot say that I am satisfied
with every single bit of information but
I can tell you that I can believe what
they're telling me
you know that was something else he
couldn't recall whether or not he spoke
about the origins of the virus in
February 2020.
well we've played that clip I don't know
how many times on the angle so I hope
he's watching now maybe it'll jog his
memory joining me now is Ben demennet
Fox News contributor and editor large of
The Spectator and Victor Davis Hanson
senior fellow at the Hoover institution
uh Ben
um
I had them on the angle I think twice
shocking he didn't come back on again
but the China question I don't know why
I felt like I have said to ask that in
February but it was revealing well it
was prescient uh I mean look I think
Laura after you know looking at that
interview clearly the science has spoken
and Anthony fauci is perfect so we just
have to accept that to deny it would be
engaging in dangerous misinformation uh
about the level of service that he has
offered us as a country no Dr fauci uh
of course has denied at every stage uh
any kind of responsibility for decisions
that he was repeatedly a critical actor
in making and I think that you know the
all of the the hullabaloo around him all
of the propaganda that we saw from the
left uh propping him up even as so many
questions were being lodged by
legitimate sources Americans who were
just raising I think very serious in
what it turned out to be significant
questions about the level that we could
trust what China was saying the level of
confidence that we had and the
conclusions that were in so many ways
affecting our lives it's really
disturbing to look at someone a
bureaucrat an unelected person not
someone responsible or responsive to any
kind of voter have that kind of power
over our lives and now at this point be
complete have complete ability to deny
any responsibility that he had for the
decision yeah no he doesn't want he
doesn't want any do-overs on anything
wow fauci was also asked about a
February 2020 phone call he had with his
Deputy at the NIH and the subject of the
call was the specifics about the nih's
ties to the Eco Health Alliance remember
that's Peter Dash X group fauci said I
wanted to be briefed on the scope of
what our collaborations were and the
kind of work that we were funding in
China I wanted to know what the nature
of that work was I didn't like the fact
that I was completely in the dark about
the totality of the work work that were
being done Victor we've been asking the
NIH about this phone call for over a
year and had heard nothing
are we to believe that Tony fauci knew
nothing about the nature of that gain of
function research that was being done at
the behest of the Eco Health Alliance
with a grant from the NIH in Wuhan
I think even his redacted emails show
that that's not true that he knew all
about it and I think the paranoia that
he had in insisting to almost the
present day that this virus originated
in the wild uh shows that and we have
now all these articles by New York
former New York Times science writer
Nicholas Wade Peter quay's book the
latest one by Dr Huff and the consensus
he knows now is that it's very likely
that this virus originated Wuhan but I
think part of our problem Laura is that
it's so huge it's staggering the truth
it's existential in the sense that did
the United States give money through
this the NIH and Dr fauci's Institute at
the National Institute of allergies and
infectious diseases and Route it through
Echo Health to avoid that it was not
legal in the United States and that
money ended up in Wuhan under the
control of the people's Liberation Army
and had some role in contributing to
this virus that's infected 800 million
people probably double that if we had
the accurate figures and killed over 70
million that's such a staggering thing
to even comprehend that right we don't
know what to do with it and I think that
he's he's got a he's a deer in the
headlights figure now he's becoming a
James Comey with 245 times Comey
couldn't remember it's the same
trajectory that these people are just
unwinding before our eyes because their
culpability is so enormous that we can't
even comprehend that anybody without
responsibility would be so reckless well
they have to have to be held accountable
he knows during his deposition he was
asked if he knew anybody who works in
social media after jamirah for a number
of responses he revealed that his
daughter used to work as a software
engineer at Twitter well they take care
of their home and it's all kind of
intertwined Twitter's where all that
disinformation was they were Banning
people Shadow Man adding them yeah I
mean as a conspiracy theory this
wouldn't even work on a TV show but look
whether she had anything to do with that
or not I think that certainly we have to
question the amount and the roles uh
that Dr fauci had in every case when it
comes to affecting the way that social
media shifted and charged this debate in
ways that we are only just now learning
about for the first time as Elon Musk
has started to unspool these things
before our eyes on a scale to one to ten
ten being the most important that's how
important it is to hold these people
accountable gentlemen thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else